( intro music )
( applause )
Mount Everest is a place
where I think I found
the most portals to discovery
for myself, personally.
Everest has been in the news
quite a bit recently
chiefly because of a
huge, devastating avalanche
that took place last April
where a number of
Nepalese climbers
predominantly from
the Sherpa ethnic group
were killed in the support of
Western mountaineers.
Of course mountaineering is
certainly by some people's view
almost an indulgent type
of a sport.
We're not going to save
anyone's life doing it.
We might actually by not
doing it save our own lives.
But where we find ourselves
and certainly what
climbers share,
I mean, amongst a variety of
different things,
perhaps a deficient sense of
hygiene amongst others.
But we have this great sense
of wanting to
impose ourselves
or place ourselves
in a humble way
inside this incredible, dynamic,
ever-changing
present environment.
Now certainly we try to
overcome this environment,
we try to work
with this environment.
As athletes we certainly have
great technical skills,
the ability to climb rock,
snow and ice.
But we also learn
technological skills
and psychological skills
to match that.
Of course the motivation
for this
is something that has been
studied certainly since
the time Everest
was first discovered
and even long before that.
What motivates climbers
to keep going to that place?
And ultimately we find ourselves
navigating our lives
through this sense of
eternity coupled
with impermanence.
And this is part of
certainly my Buddhist training,
that we essentially are
all going to
have a death of this life.
We're not going to know
where we're going to move
through into the next one.
How do we navigate this
on this great path of
self-actualization?
And certainly people like
the early explorers
going to Mount Everest
in the 1950s.
George Mallory for one,
he would've taken this picture
back in the early 1920s.
When they first actually
reached the mountain.
Of course many people know
that Mallory was a person who
uttered this great
four-word phrase
that is derivative of all human
motivation to climb Everest.
We go to climb because it's...
because it is there.
Little bit cryptic,
don't you think?
( audience laughter )
I mean, certainly it's there,
it's the highest point on Earth,
once, you know,
the cartographers and
geologists discovered that.
But Mallory would also
write later,
"you must understand that
there is something in all of us
that responds to the challenge
of this mountain
and goes out to meet it.
That the struggle is the
struggle of life itself,
upwards and forever upwards.
And, that's the reason
why we go.
For what we take from
this adventure
is nothing but sheer joy.
And joy is, after all,
the object of life.
We don't live simply
to eat and make money.
We eat and make money
so we can enjoy life.
That is what life means
and what life is for."
And you have to understand
that George Mallory's generation
was nearly decimated
in World War One.
Many of the climbers
who went on this,
these first three forays
to Everest
were all part of the military,
had lost friends,
had lost family,
had lost so many different parts
of their lives.
Many of them,
many people actually saw
the Mount Everest expeditions
as a way to
reintegrate themselves
into their real lives,
to their passionate lives
to the ones they had
before the war.
And by going out into this
challenging natural environment
that they could do this,
that they could succeed.
It's a very romantic type
of a notion that is
one that Mallory wrote
extensively about.
Of course my time on Everest
was a bit later than Mallory's.
I started climbing in 1985.
I had to fail four times
before I was able to
summit and then
the next seven times
were quite a bit easier
as a result.
But for me personally,
climbing has always been
a tool for self-actualization,
it's been a way
that I challenge myself
day in and day out.
There's always a way
that I can improve,
there's always a way that I can
rigorously analyze my approach,
there's always a way I can find
greater, more collaborative
team members.
The mountain is
always different.
The environment
is always changing.
It's a dynamic environment.
Many of the challenges
are the same, obviously.
But, you know,
like Heraclitus said,
"you never dip your foot
into river twice."
It's always different,
it's consistently changing.
So this type of environment
is one that requires
a very rigorous approach
and constant evaluation of it.
Of course for me
being on Everest,
learning about the
local cultures,
especially the Sherpa.
People who have lived in this
region for upwards of 400 years.
But we climb with the Sherpa
and we learn that
their motivations
are very different from ours.
They don't have a shred
of romance.
They are in some ways
fearful of this place.
They are also concerned about
not propitiating the spirits
by trying to climb to the
rooftop of the world.
At least some of the early
Sherpa involvement on Everest
certainly back in the 1920s
and even in
the 1950s, when
Sir Edmund Hillary
went to climb with Tenzing,
there was still this sense
of fearfulness
in many of them
that they might somehow be
violating or some way insulting
these local gods and spirits.
But in recent years
Sherpas have
with their burgeoning skills and
their craft on Everest,
they've also taken on
greater risk
because the pay is good.
And I know that many of them
have real conflicts
because they're also Buddhist
and they realize that
to actually become
and to find an incarnation
as a human being
means that you've led
a very virtuous life.
You've been really blessed
with this great human form.
His Holiness Dalai Lama said,
"the likelihood of you
arriving in human form
is like rising out of the
Pacific Ocean
with your hand through
the donut of a life preserver."
Just with a random rising
through the ocean.
So, why do you want to take on
that excessive risk?
Why do you want to threaten
that human life on your great
path of self-actualization?
Shouldn't you be doing
something like these monks
who are working towards
the betterment
of their own communities?
I've not only been a mountaineer
on Everest.
I've had the benefit to go into
the Kingdom of Mustang
and to do
archaeological research
that was featured in the
Sky Caves article couple
of years back.
It's been a great opportunity
for my family.
You can see my wife here
who's a filmmaker,
who's a big part of the team
and my daughter Cleo
is doing sound recording
on the back there.
And we do some work
with literacy,
not only in the Everest region
but also in Mustang.
We've tried early on
to instill in our kids
this great sense of service.
And to try and to get to know
and understand
the local populations.
You know, a lot of people
have described climbers
and climbing itself as being
one of the most celebrated
compulsive obsessive disorders
that's out there.
You know, I think throw in
a little bit of narcissism
and then the bad hygiene,
you kinda get a pretty good idea
of what most climbers are like.
But we try to get up
into these wild places,
some of which we have to
climb very difficult rock,
mostly because
it has little integrity.
It's almost like mud.
So we have to work
with very primitive tools
and find our way into
these caves,
that sometimes are on cliffs
that are thousands of feet high.
Of course we come out of these
caves having worked in the dust,
having worked in the mud
and we definitely look like
we've been put through
the wringer a bit.
And so, when that happens
I have to call in my son Finn,
and I really send him
in as well.
This is a real family type
of a project
and we look at our teammates
as real family members as well.
See my daughter here,
she's with
Dr. Mark Aldenderfer.
They were unraveling
one of these
remarkable gold and silver
annealed masks
that we found in one
of our caves
in a village known as Samdzong
which is right up against
the Tibetan border
in the Kali Gandaki region of
the Central Himalaya of Nepal.
Jacqueline Eng, she's not doing
a tantric ritual there.
She's actually
a bioarchaeologist
and she's studying some of the
bones to try to get an idea
of what type of lives
these people led.
She looks at bones
almost like a book.
And she can figure out
by the condition of the bones
and the type of markings on them
what the life and health
of that--
of that individual was
actually like.
Dr. Christina Warinner who does
some of the work
respective to our--
our genetic extraction
from teeth,
who's working right now on
trying to put together
a genetic genotype
that gives us an idea
of where these people are from.
And we can have,
I think a better understanding
of where the origins
of the original people
inhabiting these places are.
And we've been able to
help rewrite some of the history
of the peopling of the Himalaya
and migration through
those incredible mountains.
So, just to give you an idea
we are frequently
suspending ourselves
from ropes, climbing up
some of these remarkable
mud-encrusted,
completely unstable cliffs
using pneumatic hammer drills,
using rebar anchors
because the material is
just so difficult to bind
and so difficult to anchor in.
And it's not infrequent that
we're actually taking
extreme risk
getting up into these places
to try to push back
on our ignorance,
on this yearning for knowledge.
And ultimately for me personally
that's where it all is.
It's about self-actualization
and it's about acquiring wisdom.
It's also about inspiring
the next generation,
it's about inspiring
my own children.
And certainly as a parent,
as a husband, as a son,
I worry consistently
about having my kids
in an environment that,
you know, obviously could be
very threatening.
By the same token, as a parent
I don't want to insulate them
so much
that they never get off
the Xbox or the iPad.
And I think you parents know
what I'm talking about here.
So, in any case, I think
it's really well summarized
in a quote
by one of my favorite climbers.
His name is Edward Whymper
and in 1865
he was one of the
first people to climb
the Matterhorn for
the first time.
And he said, "Climb if you will,
but remember
that strength and courage
are not without prudence.
And that a moment's negligence
can lead to the dissolution
of happiness
in a lifetime.
Take care with each step
and do nothing in haste.
And from the beginning
think what may be in the end."
( applause )
( outro music )